I like to write out my problems that
I've encountered and so just sort of
have a timeline of them M and then to
look and say how would current me deal
with my past problems right so for
example the early stages of covid right
in March uh 2020 you have no idea what's
going on teams are worried we were
already a remote team and so we didn't
have that like shut down the office um
Dynamic but we had both a crazy amount
of growth from people being like I guess
I'll start an online business and then
also a huge amount of cancellations from
people saying like well no one's
traveling so let me shut down my travel
blog so I'm not paying for all of this
this was a very very hectic time and it
was it was really stressful but now that
I've been through that and I feel like
I'm 3 years more developed as a leader
I'm like okay I think I can manage that
just fine right and there's plenty of
other things that I remember being very
very stressed out about and now I'm like
oh that that's almost cute how simple of
a problem that
was